buenos aires ende mai flavia und rosé
kommen nicht raus corona hat alle pläne
durcheinander geworfen aber sie sind
ganz aufgeregt wie argentinia sprechen
heute mit mahnung ihrem sohn acht wochen
ist er alt und tausende kilometer
entfernt in der ukraine geboren von
einer leihmutter
letztes jahr waren flavia und rosé
schockiert
doch gerade jetzt zu - geburt reisen
unmöglich immerhin ein video an ein
liebling wir versetzen berge um bei dir
zu sein mahnung wir machen alles was wir
können
wir geben nicht auf ein gemeinsames baby
das haben flavia und rosé zehn jahre
lang versucht hinter dem paar liegt eine
lange leidensgeschichte gescheiterte
schwangerschaften und unfruchtbarkeit
therapien
am ende entschieden sie sich ein kind
über eine leihmutter in der ukraine zu
bekommen dann kam corona flüge über den
atlantik wurden gecancelt die grenzen zu
zweifel und ängste dass der traum vom
eigenen kind doch noch platzt erzählen
sie und bange fragen werden sie ihren
mahnung wirklich in ihre arme schließen
können oder war all die anstrengungen
umsonst
seit wochen sind wir gestresst
manchmal hatten wir hoffnung den rest
der zeit nicht
was in vielen ländern verboten ist hat
sich in der ukraine zu einem lukrativen
umstrittenen geschäftsmodell entwickelt
fahrer aus der ganzen welt kommen nach
kiew erfüllen sich hier ihren
kinderwunsch ganz legal baby auf
bestellung kosten bis zu 65.000 euro
ende mai wollte die größte ukrainische
leihmutter agentur mit diesem per video
auf dutzende gestrandete babys
aufmerksam machen die in einem hotel in
kiew auf ihre eltern warteten
das video ging um die welt und mit ihm
eine neue diskussion über die
leihmutterschaft
wir schätzen dass mehr als 100 kinder
von leihmüttern in der ukraine betroffen
sind kinder von bürgern verschiedener
länder aus europa asien viele aus china
die eltern der kinder kommen aus mehr
als 40 ländern firmenchef albert czapski
ist so was wie der baby baron der
ukraine
er und seine agentur standen schon öfter
in der kritik der vorwurf menschenhandel
und ermittlungen der staatsanwaltschaft
wegen steuerhinterziehung
manche sagen ich sei ein schurke ein
schlechter kerl
das ist mir aber egal hauptsache ist
dass die kunden in europa gut über mich
reden was mir hier die behörden sagen
womit sie unzufrieden sind das ist eine
andere sache ich bestechen niemanden und
die mächtigen bei uns sind immer
unzufrieden mit den geschäftsleuten
das geld ist nie genug in deutschland
kommt das budget vom staatshaushalt bei
uns aus schwarzen kassen anfang juni
geht plötzlich alles ganz schnell ein
charter flieger bringt flavia france und
andere argentinische eltern in die
ukraine
partystimmung ihrem ziel und manu ganz
nah ich viel glück und freude wirklich
unbeschreiblich dann das erste treffen
zehn wochen nach der geburt jetzt das
lassen wir alles hinter uns jetzt zählt
nur noch mal was in der vergangenheit
war bleibt dort einfach nur glücklich
quälende wochen liegen hinter den eltern
aus der ganzen welt sind sie jetzt nach
kiew gekommen um ihre kinder endlich
kennenzulernen emotional in szene
gesetzt von der leihmutter agentur den
eltern aus argentinien den usa china
oder deutschland ist das egal
sie haben es geschafft fast nach der
einreise in die ukraine mussten die
eltern wegen coroner noch mal zwei
wochen warten erstmal quarantäne stadt
babyglück so kurz vor dem ziel
wir wussten im zimmer bleiben durften
nicht mal raus strenge regeln wir haben
alles gemacht um das zu schaffen
angst frust freude all diese gefühle
hatten wir in den zwölf tagen dass ich
jetzt ein sehr gutes ende der geschichte
unglaublich
auch karin und stephan aus deutschland
das paar möchte nicht gezeigt werden
die leihmutter schenkte ihnen sogar
zwillinge zwei mädchen aber nicht jeder
soll wissen dass die kinder aus der
ukraine kommen
mit adoptionen und alles und ich wollte
auch ein afrikanisches kleines mädchen
es sollte mein mann nicht er wollte halt
lieber eigene kinder haben gesagt okay
dann müssen wir es anders machen
adoption keine option der eigene
nachwuchs kommt jetzt aus der ukraine
der kontakt zwischen eltern und
leihmutter läuft über die agentur
[Musik]
es geht um frauen wie olga die 27
jährige redet ganz offen darüber ihren
körper zur verfügung zu stellen
die meisten leihmutter kommen aus der
provinz verdienen mit anderen jobs rund
300 euro im monat und machen das
heimlich aus angst gesellschaftlich
geächtet zu werden
holger hat ein eigenes kindern ist
wieder schwanger im dritten monat und
schon zum dritten mal ist sie leihmutter
ohne dieses geld wäre sie obdachlos
15.000 dollar sollte sie beim ersten mal
bekommen am ende gab es sogar noch mehr
weil ich zwillinge bekommen habe gab es
einen zuschlag von 3000 dollar
insgesamt habe ich 18.000 dollar
bekommen ein lächerlicher zuschlag zwei
zum preis von einem
mit so viel geld konnte ich nicht
umgehen sagt olga es war schnell weg den
größten teil setzte ihr ex mann in den
sand emotionen für die ausgetragenen
kinder habe sie nicht ihrem sohn erklärt
sie dass leihmutter geschäft so von mir
nimmt das baby nichts an weil ich es
einfach austrage genetisch gehört es den
eltern
ich habe meinem sohn erzählt ich bin
einfach wie ein häuschen für das baby es
wird hier ein bisschen leben und danach
zu seinen eltern fahren mit dem geld
möchte olga jetzt eine ausbildung machen
passenderweise zur hebamme und ihr sei
es egal was andere über sie denken es
ist nicht ihr leben
und es sind nicht ihre sorgen sie werden
nicht meine miete bezahlen oder meinem
kind die schule oder öffentliche
verkehrsmittel
ihre meinung ist mir egal
wenn sie mir nicht helfen können nicht
alle leihmütter reden so offen deshalb
sprechen wir mit nennen wir sie irina
sie ist 32 hat auch schon ein kind als
leihmutter ausgetragen er man weiß davon
die familie nicht auch sie will es
wieder tun
auch für ihr eigenes kind das epilepsie
hat sie braucht das geld für medikamente
sagt sie 17.000 dollar seien ihr
versprochen worden
ich habe einen traum ein eigenes kind
wächst auf und ich will dass es eine
eigene wohnung eine zukunft hat
aber das wichtigste ist dass es auf die
beine kommt und gesund wird die
journalistin daniela poker hat intensiv
zu diesem thema in der ukraine
recherchiert und mit leihmüttern
gesprochen
sie hat erlebt unter welchem druck die
frauen oft stehen uns erzählt haben dass
manchmal eine eigene familienmitglieder
gar nicht wissen dass sie in diesem
geschäft sind die leihmutter am ende auf
die leidtragenden und sie wissen auch
nicht auf was und wen sie sich da
einlassen
das erleben sie bei der organisation
kraft der mütter jeden tag vor allem
weil in der ukraine klare gesetze fehlen
bei uns gilt die leihmutterschaft nur
als eine methode der unfruchtbarkeit
behandlungen in anderen ländern in denen
leihmutterschaft erlaubt ist wie in
georgien oder kasachstan wird das mit
bestimmten gesetzen geregelt
wenn die eltern die möglichkeit haben
sich einen anwalt zu nehmen um den
vertrag zu prüfen haben die leihmutter
diese möglichkeit nicht
und unsere hilfe wird es leichter wir
klären auf und erklären wie es sein soll
und auch wenn die leihmutterschaft in
der ukraine legal ist gibt es auch hier
immer wieder heftige kritik an diesem
geschäftsmodell vor allem von den
kirchen die vermeintlich ehrenvolle
praxis hat sich zu einem unakzeptablen
schmutzigen geschäft entwickelt die
mutterschaft ist nicht einfach nur
muttermilch mutterschaft ist heilig und
sie muss mit würde erfüllt sind
was ist richtig was ist falsch was
moralisch vertretbar beim handel mit
babys auf diese frage gibt es nicht die
eine antwort die korona krise hat auf
jeden fall ein schlaglicht auf ein
umstrittenes thema geworfen und für
flavia und rosé ist ihr traum in
erfüllung gegangen endlich mama und papa
es war ein langer kampf mit ihrem sohn
manu beginnt jetzt das familienleben
weit weg von der ukraine in argentinien